Let's talk about how we use
grid layout in Sunshine.
Our key lines guide us in laying
out the top today section.
We begin with the grid
layout declaration.
Note that we are using
the support library version, so
you will have to prefix grid layout
specific xml attributes with app, and
include the res-auto schema.
We use a column count of two.
Adding a column count
isn't strictly necessary,
as you can just specify the row and
column of each child, but
it does simplify the declaration
of each of the children.
Our first child is this space widget.
Space is a lightweight view subclass
that is used to create gaps between
components.
It can be used anywhere, but
it's actually part of the grid
layout support library.
We'll have this space widget span
both columns with a column span of 2.
We'll give it a column weight of 1, so
it will take up all available width, and
a row weight of 1, so
it will participate in getting any extra
row space when the layout is complete.
First of all, the 16 DP spaces,
using the padding horizontal material
constant from the support library,
above and below the text view, are
generated from layout margin attributes.
Remember that adding a layout
margin actually changes the borders
around your layout.
We're using material styles here.
In this case, we're using the title
style and applying the standard sans
serif font family with our secondary
text color from the material theme,
since the title text appearance uses
a different font weight and color.
Note the use of
the tools.text feature here.
This allows us to populate
the view of text for
the purposes of editing without
impacting the production code.
This view also spans both columns.
Because we want column weight to
be calculated for both columns,
we must have it here and
everywhere we declare a child.
We're finally,
actually using both columns.
As before,
we need to declare a column weight so
the grid view will
distribute the extra weight.
We're finally actually
using both columns.
As before,
we need to declare a column weight so
the gridview will distribute
the extra weight.
A couple of notes about the imageView.
I'm using maxHeight and
maxWidth along with the adjustviewBounds
to limit the size of our weather image.
This allows more flexibility in layout.
But still allows us to have a theme
image that may be larger than our layout
size.
The image view also uses a source
tag with a tools names based,
to display an image
in the editors tools.
We set up the forecast text view and the
low temperature text view in the same
way as the columns in the previous row.
Note that we were actually giving
the low temperature text zero margin,
which is applying across both columns.
Finally, we add another space
widget with a row weight
to keep the rest of the content centered
within the grid layout, and that's it.
We had the top of our detail layout,
which is included from detail today,
grid.xml.
The rest is up to you.